Justin Bieber just dropped his new album
changes today making it the perfect
Valentine's Day gift yeah now it's his
first album in more than four years and
while sitting down with Apple musics
beats wonho Zane lo Justin admitted the
new album is all about his wife Haley
I'm frigging married down and I got the
best wife in the world she supports me
through so much I'm really honored to be
her husband and I just really have made
a whole album about it yeah and there's
more to come I mean I want to continue
to write about what it looks like to be
it's so you know this is an album I
wrote in the first year of our marriage
you know so it's like it's so fresh and
there's you know there's no there's so
much more to learn about commitment and
you know building trust and foundation
I'm just I'm looking forward to
continuing to build and make music
that's gonna reflect that this was great
about changes it's a honeymoon right
yeah yeah it's I can't even record
exactly you know it would be sort of
disingenuous to start diving deeper into
that situation when you're just learning
about it at the beginning [ __ ] out
ages yeah so I think I think I'm like
I'm excited about this but I'm just like
there's so much more there's so much
deeper levels I'm excited to go to which
is fun you know it gives me something to
look forward to I think in the past I
was so caught up in all of like the bad
things in my life that I just I wasn't
able to really take take a second and
really appreciate all the all the little
things but yeah I'm excited it's gonna
be it's gonna be good
Oh Justin I still see him like the 16
year old with no baby it's like it's
just like it was like yesterday he's 14
and just like but here he is he's going
man any of the mustache right and he's
friggin married he's me her also stopped
by The Tonight Show where he tried to
teach Jimmy Fallon how to play hockey
and let's just say Fallon is about as
good at hockey as I am which is to say
awfully Rob we have five bucks wherever
gets posted in wins we're gonna head to
head stick the stick don't say that head
head is gonna speak neither
[Music]
here comes the Irishman here we go stay
up Jimmy spit yeah
[Music]
growing up we cut you're over there
[Music]
ten
that's gonna haunt your dreams baby baby
shut the tignous baby shower
my god
oh my god
oh my god you are so good
Oh
[Applause]
not surprised in the least that Justin
Bieber is like a pro hockey like not
only obviously is the Canadian rate
you're suppose it's supposed to be in
the genes like you're supposed to get it
I guess of course I never got it he's
sensitive about it you remember in that
first documentary yeah where it showed
him just being gifted at everything
every time I know it's wild okay so so
far and I can be really honest and I
don't want hate but it's okay
um I I don't know if I've been loving
all of the most recent music coming from
Bieber yeah you know how they say maybe
it's cuz he's really happy you know how
they say the best songs coming I'm
really getting the sense that he's so
happy he's so happy with his new wife
now this doesn't just say that I've
listened to every single song I still
need to like do a full deep dive this
weekend which I'm really looking forward
to um but I don't know if there's
anything that's really caught my
attention just yet I'm a bit of an
island you think well I'm a bit of an
island around the office because I like
the song you're liking the song yeah
yummy song yeah okay wait what I'm like
I think it's I think it's great I like
it a lot I mean it's not like they're
all the best songs I've ever heard
yeah but I like them I listen to them
right okay now some comments on YouTube
caliche saying purpose was a lot better
which is his last album yesterday it was
so I expected so much more looking at
the time he took before putting it out
right because there is like that pretty
big spam there Noah saying I haven't
heard it yet but I will give it a try no
shade but it seems a bit mediocre so
much stuff right now but there's so much
music so much good music and I feel like
there's like a sea change and what
things are listening to yeah in terms of
even just the pop sounds at there that
they're crafting so I don't know maybe
it's just maybe it's a timing thing yeah
maybe I'm not sure now someone said that
they're actually protesting the album
until he shaves there's definitely some
comments about the mustache do we like
the mustache right listen I'm you can
grow a mustache can you can we just
Movember attempt I'm just saying
Bieber's was better what I'm saying is
this I support anyone that can grow one
for real okay because it's
it's a no it's always not always you
know what